[Musik]
hallo Leute und Willkommen zu vlogmas
Tag 10 heute werden wir
schifon und meine Skala von dem
Angstlevel ist so 11 von 10 wieder mal
sehe ich cute aus ihr kennt das Outfit
schon ich muss leider sagen ich habe in
Mailand paar Kilo zugenommen und jetzt
passe ich nicht mehr so gut in mein
[Musik]
tieranzugck das Gefühl kennen wir ja
schon
ne oh mein
gottitze ist so heiß in diesem Zeug
schie ready for the mountain ready m
dieser
Ausblick ballert einfach immer noch
das schmeckt ne so cool das einfach ist
oder und da läuft sie Richtung Berg als
ob sie nie was anderes getan hätte
kurzer Zwischenstand wir sind ja jetzt
auf dem Weg nach draußen und dann fahren
wir jetzt mit dem Skilift Gondel was
auch immer auf den Berg und es wird
wirklich das erste Mal sein dass ich
auch auf so einem verdammten Berg war ne
also versteht mich nicht falsch das ist
als ob ich das erste Mal das Meer sehe
oder so könnte man schon verich
Vergleich Zehen ja auf jeden Fall der
Ausblick aus unserem Zimmer und vom
Frühstücksplatz war heute auch atberau
schön wir haben den mathorn gesehen der
mathorn da einfach casual ne casual am
flexen deror komplett normal ja klar das
istmer der Horn ja stell mal hinter
ihn h
wier wie echter Profi steckt ihre schier
da rein das ist für
Sie jetzt nichts anderes gegeben in
ihrem Leben ne ja nur ich bin Level
aufgestiegen zu Stöckern ja ich habe
ohne Stöcker gelernt ich sag wie es ist
wie empfindest du die Kälte warte in die
gegenerichte zum Berg warte mal ich
fahre und ich biege mich zum Tal und
drehe mich zum Berg so und dann biege
ich mich zum Tal und drehe mich zum Berg
oh ich glaube da hinten kommt Sven
meinst du K es Sven in the red jeder
könnte hier Sven sein
point
das erste Mal in zm oder ja gut ich habe
heute das erste Mal oder gestern das
erste Mal Berge gesehen ah ja ja ich
komme aus Hamburg das ist alles flach da
gibt's gar nichts okay dann seid ihr
gestern direkt von Hamburg hieran
gereist von Berlin nee von Mailand ja
wir waren schon wir machen gerade so
eine kleine Christmas Tour okay jetzt
waren wir f Tage in Mailand und genau
jetzt und dann wollten wir nach Basel
und dann dachten wir warum nicht
Skifahren dazwischen und wo warst den in
der in der
Halle in
bisbing das ist auch bei Hamburg da so
wir haben jetzt getroffen und fahren
hoch ja auf den Berg let's
[Musik]
[Applaus]
go eine Metro genau fährt automatisch ja
ne ja braucht kein Führer kein
Lockführer oder
so
Schellen wir uns
dain so g quasi immer so kleine K ja
voll ir voll modern voll geil ja bin
drafgewachsen wahrscheinlich das erste
Mal mit zwei
Jahren du bist hier wirklich
aufgewachsen hat ich gestern noch mich
gefragt so wie ist das woh hier
aufzuwachsen dass das völlig normal ist
weil für uns ist es ja richtig verrückt
diese Berge drum rum zu haben ja es ist
schon schön aber gestern auch habe ich
auch einheimische Kinder getroffen und
die sind dann ich weiß nicht 18 Jahre
alt und die sind dann alleine irgendwo
am schlitteln die Eltern fragen nicht
wirklich nach da bist du ja du hast
einfach viel Freiheit hier als Kind als
zum aufwachsen ist schön was GI hier so
im Sommer zu tun also ist man jetzt hier
am Skifahren und dann im
Sommer Skifahren kann man ja das ganze
Jahr echt ja ist auf Gletscher er ist
dann auf
3800 m
Höhe und da kannst du das ganze Jahr
fahren eine kleine Pisse mit so
bügelliften und so aber ja
kannst ja gibt's aber im Moment ist sie
glaube ich noch nicht offen die machen
jetzt ein ganzen Schnee das ist dann für
die Hochsaison die Beginn ich weiß nicht
16 18 dezember für dann ist es dann
sicher bereit wir fahren hier wirklich
im highpeed im Berg
hoch und die
ohrenenü zü ich gewöhne Timo hier an
falsche
[Musik]
Sachen gehen wir hier runter nach links
volpark ja da üben die Leute S auch
erwachsen ja ja ja ja
ja wie natürlich er da so lang läuft
[Musik]
neich auf
wäre ja gut also wir beginnen mal
einfach ja du hast ja schon dre Stunden
gehabt also wirst du das damit keine
Mühe haben wir gehen mal nur in einen
Ski super wir laufen nur mal und sliden
so ein bisschen auf dem Schnee mal
schauen wie sich das anfühlt du kannst
auch mal so ein bisschen die Kante
fühlen oder das ist dann deine Bremsung
später hier die Kante gut gut dann gehen
wir schon beide
Ski gut mit Stöcker man kann sich
festhalten schau jetzt kannst du mir die
Stöcke geben dann kannst du mir danach
die Hand geben nein sie fährt schon
ab ich lehne mich zum Tal genau und
drücke mit den Kanten zum
Berg
das ist dein Test deine Aufnahmeprüfung
für den steileren Hang du schaffst hier
durch diesen slalum zu fahren das sind
diese vier Kurven dann gehen wir danach
in ins bisschen steilere Gelände keines
darf ausgelassen werden Versuch
okay
ich vergess das mit den Stöckern total
was ich machen muss nur auf die Beine
konzeren rechte Bein die Belastung genau
und dann
geht ja das ist es das ist
es das ging ja jetzt Level level
up sehr gut
[Musik]
wie sah es aus sehr gut
sch jetzt er lügt mich bestimmt an ist
es wir steiler ne ne wird nicht viel
steiler du musst es mir ernsthaft sagen
vielleicht einmal kurz aber eigentlich
die war sehr entspannt die Strecke hier
die andere Seite da ist deutlich steiler
[Musik]
okay stark Messer wirklich mega
cool du hast de erste Abfahrt geschafft
oder oh mein Gott ST ist
wirklich bravo bravo ich habe das Glück
ich habe das Gefühl mehr Glück als
können dahinter oh mein wie
cool
mega wirklich bin
beeindruckt die meisten die brauchen
wirklich also ein Tag mindestens und du
nach Z
Stunden sehr
[Musik]
gut
h mir getan super also wenn ihr in der
Schweiz seid Bucht euch gerne den Sven
ne ist für euch am Start ins Herm ja
Schweiz ist ein bisschen größer da ist
sie sie hat den Berg
bezwungen die erste Abfahrt genommen die
Welt steht ihr
offen Leute ich habe das vor dem
Skifahren noch nie erlebt dass man vor
etwas Angst hat vor einer Sache die
passieren könnte in dem Fall hinfallen
und dann passiert Leute ich habe das
noch nie vorher in meinem Leben erlebt
und es fühlt sich so gut an das
Schifahren auch das macht richtig Spaß
aber das das Schlimmste passiert was man
sich vorstellen konnte dass man hinfällt
und so ein bisschen die Kontrolle
verliert und danach steht man wieder auf
und macht weiter das ist geisteskrank
dieses Gefühl ich fühle mich als ob ich
alles schaffen könnte im
Leben also die erste Abfahrt lief glaube
ich wie auch in bisbing also die erste
Abfahrt lief richtig
gut ich bin paar mal richtig schnell
geworden habe aber immer noch die
Kontrolle wieder zurückbekommen die
zweite Abfahrt ich merke dann halt dass
ich müde bin dann weiß ich schon so uh
da sind schon stellen dann weiß ich
schon wovor ich Angst haben kann dann
kriege ich diese Angst und dann bin ich
auch zweimal hingefallen aber ich muss
sagen diesesm fühle ich mich nicht nach
weinen und
aufgeben das hinfallen ist ich echt
nicht so schlimm wie man denkt und ja
also es sind ja es sind ja so also hier
fahren ja Leute Ski die machen das ja so
krass ne die fahren so richtig schnell
runter und man selbst ist da so ein
bisschen ängstlicher sage ich mal
unterwegs aber man muss sich halt nur
auf sich selbst konzentrieren und das
hat mir auch noch mal voll gut geholfen
dass es auch mehr Spaß bringt und ich
einfach den Moment genieße und auf mich
selber konzentriere und gucke dass ich
meine Abfahrt hinkriege und nicht die
ganze Zeit irgendwie nach links und
rechts und bin ich immer mit im Weg und
so das ist wirklich ja
krass ist einfach krass ist ein krasses
Gefühl muss ich sagen und Timo ist am
besten dass Timo der ganze so mega stolz
auf mich ist ich glaub so stolz war du
noch nie im Leben ich habe gestrahlt wie
ein Honigkuchenpferd Leute ich bin
hinterher gefahren ich so das ist das
ist mein
Mädchen